[Music]
well the percentage of foreign-born in
the United States is the highest it's
been in a century maybe ever it's hard
exactly to know but it's still rising in
any case 67 million Americans more than
one in five speak a language other than
English at home pretty much everyone in
Washington is fine with that number
rising some of them want the u.s. to
completely open his borders to the rest
of the world but what would the effect
be if we did that who is coming here
what are they like and where's all of
this going look at this numbers we are
joined by Steven Cammarata director of
research at the Center for Immigration
Studies he joins us tonight um Steven
just the first obvious observation
people when I was a kid used to care
about overpopulation I guess nobody does
anymore
yeah that's it's a fair question the
latest census bureau numbers indicate
that immigration by 2060 will add 75
million people to the US population so
you'd think people concerned about the
environment or traffic pollution
congestion sprawl what would would think
about that turns which I will admit as a
kid yeah I moxa liberals for having but
as I get older I realize they do not
want to live in a crowded place
everyone's unhappy it's horrible and
it's dirty so does anyone on the Left
still say that there are a few
progressives out there you may know the
new Organization numbers USA they have a
lot of progressive support and they tend
to focus a lot on population growth but
most mainstream people on the Left don't
touch it with a ten-foot pole because
it's all in the United States about 95
percent of population growth long term
is new immigrants and the children they
have and so they don't want to touch the
issue wait what percentage of
populations about 95 percent between now
and twenty sixty about 95 percent of the
increase in the US population will come
from future immigrants and the children
and grandchildren Ohio so that's almost
a complete turnover in population
basically no that's population growth
that's about 75 million people okay so
most of all the increase is coming from
immigration so from about 328 to 404 is
about where we're headed something like
that so the language numbers are really
interesting to me one in five yeah
people living in this country does not
speak English at home has it ever been
that high it's hard to say but it may
have been that high in the past what's
even more interesting or perhaps more
troubling is how concentrated it is so
there are all kinds of areas where the
Census Bureau divides the
entering the various areas where 95% of
the people are 85% of the people and 95
and 85% of the people in schools kids in
schools speak a foreign language at home
that's what's truly extraordinary one
wonders how assimilation can work with
that level of immigration and foreign
language concentration so what what are
broadly speaking the education levels of
the immigrants who are coming here
it varies enormously course it does so
you know you're looking at a situation
where 80 percent plus of immigrants from
India come with a college degree or more
and then for say immigrants from Central
America it's less than 10 percent come
with a college degree and the same thing
for immigrants that break down so what
percentage of our immigrants are coming
with no education versus those coming
with high degrees but yeah right now
somewhat over 1/4 of all immigrants have
less than a high school education when
they come a little over 1/4 also have no
more than a high school education so a
high school education or less is a
little over half and then a little less
than half is some college or even
college and more so that's the very
rough break so the majority have high
school education or less or less right
so no education beyond high school and
we know from a lot of research that
their welfare use in poverty is quite
high
of course across the board seem
Cammarata thank you very much thank you
have indeed well you just heard as
millions of people many of them
low-skill half continue to enter this
country an obvious question arises what
does that mean for our economy for
America's working class which is already
having its jobs phased out by automation
but for a lot of other parts of our
society
Oren Cass is a senior fellow Manhattan
Institute author of the book the once
and future worker a vision for the
renewal of work in America thoughtful
look at that question he joins us
tonight or and thanks all for coming up
thank you for having me check this so
there's a debate over what automation is
going to do long term everyone seems
agreed that it's going to eliminate a
lot of jobs that we currently think of
Israel jobs they'll be gone but is there
any scenario in the future as we
perceive it now where you'd want more
than half all immigrants to have a high
school diploma or less I think that's a
concern we have to grapple with if we
already feel like we have an imbalance
too many unskilled workers relative to
what the economy wants adding more
unskilled
here's to that mix pushes us in the
wrong direction how concerned are you
about that I think it's a concern I
think it's it's one among many I think
there are a lot of things we're doing
that really hurt less skilled workers
the way we approach immigration the way
we approach education I mean we don't
care about education for less skilled
workers we say College for all and if
you don't complete college you just you
fell out somewhere along the way and all
of our money goes to the folks who are
actually completing college even though
they're the ones who need the least help
so why wouldn't you if you were thinking
thoughtfully about hula if you started
with the presumption that some
immigration is good that's where ice
start anyway why wouldn't you be
thoughtful about letting in more people
who already have the education that you
think your economy requires I think
that's exactly what we should do and I
think you know most economists would
look at the issue and say if you want to
benefit workers at the bottom if you
want to benefit their wages pretty much
the models say high-skilled immigration
is good for low-skilled workers more
low-skilled immigration it can't be good
for low-skilled workers you're just
adding more competition to the market
does and I've had this debate a hundred
times on the show over the past couple
of years and I often hear people say all
the studies show that's not true
bringing in millions more poor people
makes us all richer is there such a
study that shows that I'm not aware of a
study that shows that there are a lot of
studies that show that the mix of
immigrants we've had over time which has
been low skilled and high-skilled has
its reflected roughly what's in the
population right and so that's ok but
that's the wrong question to ask the
question asked is which would be better
given that we're going to have
high-skilled immigration is it good to
also have a lot of low-skilled
immigration or is it good to have less
low-skilled immigration and what you
would say is the less low-skilled
immigration you have the better things
are gonna be for the low-skilled workers
who are here so I sort of allotted over
the meat of your book which is what
would you if you could do one thing to
help people who are struggling to reap
the benefits of our economy what would
it be well I think conceptually we have
to actually value work and we have to
say it's not just about consumption and
how much we all get to consume and how
cheap stuff is we actually have to
realize that people having work is
what's most important to them and then
wait a second paying everybody off with
3 grand
a month won't be the answer oh it's a
disaster it's a great answer for the
folks who are doing really well the
funny thing is the higher up the income
ladder you go the more people say oh not
everyone needs a job people we can send
the money you go down to the bottom end
for the ladder that's where you find the
people who say no we don't just want
money we want the jobs because they
understand how critical work is not just
to their own satisfaction their own
lives to their families to their
communities and if we don't focus on
that if we just say oh we'll grow will
grow the pie what they say right we'll
just we'll just send everyone a piece
right you don't have to bake your own
pie we'll just give you a slice that's
not what people want and that's not a
model for a good society that used to be
really obvious it did until about the
middle of the last century and then we
flipped and we said as long as as long
as consumption keeps going up as long as
everyone can have more stuff every year
we're gonna call that success but that's
not success brightly-colored crap made
in China will make us happy did it I
don't see a lot of that no don't either
foreign caste really thoughtful thank
you for that thanks for having me